there's Oh joins us at the table is oh
we love that little tiny purse moment
and you just said you know I like to
have fun Gail well guess what we like to
have fun too anything will you do the
honors since you're sitting so close we
thought you needed a little cup to go
along with your little purse that's a
CBS mini cup yeah we got one too
[Laughter]
interesting yeah so eight Grammy
nominations you said it feels special it
does that it feels like infinity
you couldn't possibly dream this for
yourself not about your wildest know
you've been working at this for a very
long time yes I mean I've been I've been
a successful musician a touring musician
for a long time I was an indie artist I
have my own label I got signed to an
imprint in Atlantic and I was good I was
like this is great I'm a career musician
I have a fanbase I'm selling out tours
I'm good my wildest dreams have been
realized you would have been happy with
that happy with that so how would you
describe what happened it's this thing
that we always talk about because you
need a few things to have successes like
of course there's a talent there's a
drive the work ethic but there's this
x-factor that nobody quite can put their
finger on and we always talked about it
like that weird thing that magic that
happens in someone's career that is what
happened there was just a moment where
somehow as culture abdun flowed I caught
on to that wave and everyone just
connected with me like you can never
really choose when that moment comes but
it's your attitude to and your outsize
personality to don't you think I got a
big old person at sorry I mean look at
you now it is very hard to believe that
at one point before you were successful
touring music musician before you were a
big mainstream success you were living
in your car playing music for food is
that true person is probably watching
this on their phone catching Wi-Fi from
the donut shop across the street in
their car right now right you get
through that moment to NAT to where you
are today that's the key word like
through the only way you get through
something is to move forward yeah and I
think that I had so many moments where I
wanted to give up and I was like why am
I still doing this is so hard you wanted
to give
Oh twice in my life what did you say
what what did you tell yourself um well
the first time I said you know I'm doing
this for my family it was really
important to me I don't know why but
like our 21 year old girl was like the
baby of her family was like I have to
take care of my mother and my brother
and my sister and that was the thing
that drove me to continue yeah and then
the second time which was when truth
hurts first came out I was like man I'm
really tired and I and I think that if I
put music out nobody would care like I'm
not making a splash something told me to
just keep going because I had to make
music yeah it literally is the joy of my
life yeah I have your early supporters
was Prince ah what did he do for you
Prince made the day before and the day
after leaving Paisley Park like
transformed me from just like a musician
to an artist I think I learned how to be
an artist what's the difference the
difference is is you know I have talent
I can sing I can rap I can play an
instrument I can write songs but an
artist creates art with those things you
know you can do and then you can create
art and I learned how to kind of marry
my sounds I have so many different weird
styles and I was shy about them and
insecure and I didn't know which one I
was better at but you don't have to be
better at either any of them he gave you
that yourself
he gave gave it to me yeah well that's
what people like about you Liz oh
because you are so uniquely yourself
Anthony's daughter I have to tell you TV
audience Olivia who never comes to CBS
came this morning because she wanted to
see Liz oh and I said what is it Olivia
better she said because you were always
unapologetically yourself mm-hmm which
leads me to the Lakers game people are
talking about you so I want to know I
was having a conversation with my friend
Wendy this morning who said listen she's
an entertainer she's always on that's
just that's just a personality she's
she's a performer other people say okay
Liz oh we get it you're proud of your
body body positivity but you're at the
Lakers game enough with your body what
is your response to that
um cuz you've heard some of the flack
that you've been getting it but not
really okay totally and my own positive
you know you don't even take it all in
well it's their opinion so I mean it's
not for me to really ingest it's for
them to express and for me to choose to
listen to or not or not um you know I
was at a spontaneous moment yeah
absolutely was I think no one would have
ever saw what I was wearing like the
back of it if I didn't get up and dance
and the Lakers girls came up to me and
said we're so excited that you're here
we want to perform one of your songs for
you and I remember I was sitting there
and I was with my manager and my friend
and they were like you should get up and
dance like they're doing this for you I
was like alright so I got up and I just
did what I always do anyone who knows me
knows that this is how I've always been
this is how I've always liked to dress
and it's a bit did you forget your butt
was out just curious how do layers hug
down there so my my it wasn't just you
know flesh two seats oh you know you
know a lot of you contrary to popular
belief it was yeah you've talked about
you're okay with it being out okay with
this body in there my butt was my least
favorite thing about myself
and I learned to love it and that was
the thing everybody can't stop talking
about people you should be a role model
in fact you are being a role model even
in that in that moment be you do you
don't ever let anybody take or steal
your joy especially not the internet so
of you have you enjoyed this success
because I think did I hear the the
periods of times you've been kind of
depressed
yes but I mean I wouldn't be human if I
didn't you know have times where the
balance where the highs and the lows
kind of happened yeah um I accept that I
think Fame is a little hard to take from
me it was never my plan yeah I love
being successful and I love playing
music and making my team is a different
animal though it is not famous
yes so when the favor successful and
famous this time magazine Entertainer of
the Year
[Laughter]
cheering you on the job Jamil come on
always cheering congratulations on an
amazing year thank you and you were so
nice to Olivia thank you thank you and
you can watch the 62nd annual Grammy
Awards on Sunday January 26 right we're
at Liz OH
right here on CBS that's the time